that's bull took me three weeks to make
us really
[Music]
this thing here is called this Dewar
idea what it's like a big service is
like a big glorified one of these things
when I was asking just mean what we
should do it's liquid nitrogen she said
will it blend so we're going to try to
mix it up for these we're going to melt
the ice cream first I got a piece of
styrofoam in here just kind of blocking
out the mouth when we pulled out it you
can see kind of cryogenic vapor that
walks out with it there is a lot of
liquid in there which we're going to
transfer into this thermos just for
convenience is one of the fatty
substances on earth but it won't freeze
you right away okay wait for you the
body oh yeah holy crap this is so neat I
believe what's happening right now
so I'm just going to stop it there first
thing we're going to have that thermos a
second to cool down look at how it's
going crazy it's actually making like a
little vortex or a cyclone in there yep
because it's extracting all the view
from the plot something's going down the
line here cracking yes yeah what do I do
now it's a bit more upright
okay get more on there no up right up
right near you
I'm so scared over the trap
oh I spilled on the floor is that bad
gone already
it's gone it's gone already okay so we
will put that right over there you can
see it's nice and maybe liquid nitrogen
it is one of the coldest substances on
earth but if you're quick enough you can
actually put your fingers into it
Wow without freezing them and if you
accidentally spill some on your
countertop yeah start you may start
skittling around Wow and just like flows
right up see that look at little bit
really this won't leave this one so now
the question is liquid nitrogen so cold
that if we pour it into a blender the
glass will crack if it cracks and spills
out that's no did we kind of losers
dance little anti-climatic although that
would look cool true but now if
something starts happening should we use
unplugged
I guess we'll find out how we get - yeah
but I can do all right so we've got our
ice-cream nicely mixed up and melted are
you okay if you do it here hand just
like wiggle your hand a little bit
yeah what's cool right there okay so now
what do we do
so let's just go ahead and set these
down right there this to those spikes at
the top we got to make sure we don't
puncture and I guess I'm going to have
to kind of lean that in say the gloves
number safety should we move maybe the
fire extinguisher you know what I love
about this is we're doing what nice to
do we just have a random fire
extinguisher hanging around any of our
last video which you need to go check
out on my channel
oh my god it's incredible it because I
light on fire so you got a little fire
should we move that like I don't know
what's going to happen I'm not a good
yeah maybe we'll move everything do I
need my lab coat you know things are
getting serious when you start busting
out the lab coat
all right sort of I do this safety
measures in place yes all right I'm
gonna go to top the bottom and we're
second button it from the left so we
have a bunch of different options we
have blind dice pure Asians his pure a I
think kind of like grinding because I
want to like grind bottomless IRA foam
cup and just watch the nitrogen speed
ballot they watch the bottom here and
those that tears open we're going to see
probably a lot of vapor you got the shot
yeah I get closer you can't it's okay
he's he's our friend
alright ready oh my god I'm so scared oh
my gosh look at all the vapor that's
freaking me out
Wow shucky with the bottom looking on
yes
it's actually sitting inside the
Farrakhan topless pleaser it's actually
spinning inside the couple I think that
I think the styrofoam got stuck for the
blender blade think it did go ahead and
pull that out oh yeah it is second I
forget that
[Music]
ice cream in there that's frosty all
right so I'm going to fish some of these
styrofoam chunks out put that on and
just watch the nitrogen by itself yeah
yeah yeah yeah I can't keep this thing
on it keeps popping off all the pressure
keeps popping it off oh not only that I
think this is kind of like frozen solid
that is amazing doc should we throw some
ice cream in there so with all those
styrofoam chunks I don't know if that'd
be appetizing but look at this all of
our nitrogen is almost gone
Wow look that happened fast let's keep
let's go ahead and like turn on one more
time with the lid off I'll go off the
rest of the nitrogen all right so yeah
go to puree
[Music]
there we go anything left nope nothing
but Colbert you really impressing me
about this blender is that it's the
container help us with the nitrogen like
it $26.00 blender though I was so afraid
it was going to break it is quote I was
expecting to crack and all the nitrogen
to leak out like these are cryogenic
temperatures we really really really fun
just to get some hot water like boiling
on the stove and then like as that
spinning pour the boiling water in well
what will happen epicness will happen
alright the water I've never used this
popular before so why not use it to quit
liquid nitrogen boiling water this was
this cup that's all the damage slender
did and then the come to started
spinning freely inside the container
like now that's starting to warm up the
bottom of the blog after I'm sorry if
you could actually see it cracking in
real time
we should put a little nitrogen air flow
back out and I think it warms up a
little bit too much well I guess while
this is heating up what would happen if
we dumped some of it just into the ice
cream that's a good idea
we've never tried this before liquid
nitrogen ice cream I know it has been
done but it hasn't been done by us or my
kitchen we have melted ice cream mix in
the microwave it's actually quite warm
and I don't know how much is too much so
that's good that's good anything well I
can't see this was like thinkin of a
witch's brew
oh yeah it's nasty out on my hand no ohh
coughing up Oh Robin ankle it's like
bubbling on the bottom which like story
on that or what water great alright yeah
you got all this clunking up on here
that looked a lot like ice cream you
want to try a bite in to see how it
tastes
you know I was thinking like you might
want to try it first let me know how I'm
not just left us intolerant okay I'll do
the trick so what's the worst that can
happen
hmm I think we're getting there see like
if you look at this right now you can
see like some of us clumping up the cool
thing about this is because we're not
adding water or like chunks of ice they
want to loot the case at all so just
something that's safe I love it
yeah let's go at that it's not what just
made us all here it's a nice pancake I
think we got the consistency of like a
soft-serve now oh wow
and I'm just like stirring them to get
rid of some of those chunks it's fine to
eat though right oh yeah
well we think of like what's in the
atmosphere it's 79 percent nitrogen that
you're breathing in oh and 20 percent
oxygen I mean this was nitrogen but now
that it's transferred the cold the
nitrogen is gone so it really is just
ice cream Wow reverse engineered ice
cream is good that is good that's how
you rejuvenate your ice cream after it's
like melted yeah spenfree minute making
listen magic in your basement like
totally totally calm we're good
definitely worth it and we bust some hot
water that's been boiling on the stove
we're going to dump in there just for
fun I love fun what's going to happen
you know what's going to happen I have
an idea
okay this seems to be resilient enough
in fact this our last experiment yeah
we'll just for the hope oh wow that's a
lot right there you're looking at about
$15 for liquid nitrogen books worth it
we want to pulse it was amazing I love
how yous like jumped in like your hand
just got chopped off give me a minor
heart attack there I just like out of my
gloves do you still have a pulse
sure
oh wow did you hear that yeah that was
something
yeah the gears are starting to grind get
that already I got nothing to say to
that that was amazing that was amazing
liquid nitrogen is completely gone it
just went up it with one acute puff of
smoke and I tried pouring a little bit
more water but it just stayed in there
you can see I I think other than making
a huge mess that to be completely
destroyed this blender now if you look
down inside you can see all the glass is
cracked
the blades are still intact but I don't
think it's gonna be usable again cry I'm
crying because I'm freaking out yeah are
you doing over there I am letting it out
so I think it you weren't expecting that
no no I'm crying these aren't me I think
you like tears of excitement happiness
because I was like I don't even you know
what we just did I think we just made
like a cloud making the same like for
real right oh my god
[Music]
does he
and they will be size
[Music]
these are tears of joy guys what happens
that moment you realize you can make
clouds in the kitchen for real thanks
for coming over
- mission complete thank you so much for
for joining me for this experiment
because this is something I could have
never done by myself I needed adult
responsible adult supervision
that's qualifier we Came we made a mess
we conquered yes well thank you so much
for watching and thank you so much for
joining me make sure you guys check out
his channel I'll put a link in
description and also to a video that we
did where we did a little something like
that yeah I'll see you guys there
we come
[Music]